So here's one way to define make_hashtable. We're going to start by
initializing a variable i = 0. So we're going to start by creating
an empty table and what we want to do is add
n buckets, number of buckets to the table. So we're going to use
a while loop and we're going to loop while i is less
than number of buckets. So each time that I want to go
through the loop what we want to do is add on empty
bucket to our hash table. So we can do that using Append.
That adds a new empty bucket and we need to
remember to increase I to make sure that we don't
keep looping forever. So we're going to go through this
loop nbuckets number of times each time adding an empty bucket
to the table and then we need to return the
table at the end. So let's try that in the Python
interpreter. So here's the code just like we read out
and we'll print out the result of making a hash table.
We'll keep the number of buckets small for printing. For a real
use were going to want to have many more than three buckets. And let's
run that. And we see what we got is a list with
three empty lists as it's elements. So this works okay. It seems like
a lot more code than we need. And it is more code
than we need. There's a better way to write this, which is to
use a four loop. So, the general structure we've seen for four
loops. Alright. We've seen a loop that has, has a structure like this,
where the collection could be a list. It could be
a string. [SOUND] To have a four loop, we need some
set of objects that we're looping through. In this case, what
we want to do is loop through the numbers from 0 to
n buckets minus 1. So we want to create a list
that contains those values. So we, what we would like in
order to be able to define a procedure like make hash
table, is to have a list, which is the numbers from
0 to n buckets minus 1. Python provides an easy
way to do that, its called range. So range takes
two numbers, as inputs. The start and the stop number.
And what it outputs is a list of all the
numbers from start up to stop minus 1. So this
is what ranges outputs, a list of numbers, starting from
start. Increasing by 1, until we get to stop minus
1. We'll note that it doesn't include the value passed
in is the second parameter in the list. This turns
out to be useful because oftentimes when we look through
elements, we don't want to include the last element. So
that means if we evaluated something like range 0,10, the
result would be the list 0,1,2, up to 9. So
now that we know about range. We could change our loop
here. Instead of having this while loop, we could do
the for loop. And we prefer this for two reasons. The
first is it's going to make our code shorter. Anytime we
can make code shorter, that's usually a good thing. The second
is, it saves us from the danger of forgetting to increment
the variable. This is a common mistake, and when we forget
to increment the variable, the loop's just going to run forever. So
if we can write our while loops as for loops, that's usually
a good idea. So a better way to define the catch table
is to use the for loop. We're no longer going to need the
variable i. We still need table and now instead of using a
y loop we're going to use a for loop. We're going to leave the
variable name blank for a second, we'll figure out what to put
there later, and what we're looping through. Is from the range from
0 up to nbuckets. So we want to look through the
elements of the list range to nbuckets. That's going to be the
list of numbers from zero to nbuckets, minus 1. And for
each one of those we want to append, one new bucket to
the table, just like we did before. We don't need
to increment i, there's not i variable now. And at the
end of the loop, we return the table just as before.
For this loop, we didn't actually need a variable here, right?
We never used the variable inside. For this index of the
four loop, well, we still need something here, so I'm just
going to call the variable unused. To make it clear that we
have a name there. We don't actually use it in the body
of the formula. So this makes the code a lot smaller.
It will work the same way as what we had before.
So here's the new code. Several lines shorter than what we
had before. Does exactly the same thing. If you were really clever,
you might have thought of an even shorter way.
To define make hash table, that unfortunately doesn't quite
work. So the shorter way would be to guess,
that the times operator works on list, the same
way it worked on strings. So we could do
this by creating empty list, times nbuckets. This seems
great, it's only one line, really clear and easy
to understand, and it looks like it almost works.
So let's try that in the Python interpreter. And it looks like
it worked, we've got a hash table, a list with three empty
buckets. There's one big problem with this approach, and I'll show you
a hint why it is, and then we'll have a quiz to see
if you can figure out why. So now instead of just printing
out the result. We're going to assign it to a variable called table, and
now we're going to mimic what would happen when we add something to
the hashtable. That means we're going to add something to one of the buckets.
Let's pick bucket one, and let's assume
we're going to add the entry for udacity with
one url. And now we can print out
what's in that bucket. Looks like everything is
okay. What about what's in bucket zero? Now
we get the same result. So, think about
what went wrong. I'm going to ask a quiz to see if you can understand why this
simpler definition of make hash table doesn't actually work correctly.